[MUSIC]
Welcome, everybody.
Hello, my name is Wil Torres.
I am one of the admission officers at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
I am so excited to be here today.
STEM, sciences, earth,
environment are near and dear to my heart,
as well as to our panelists.
One of the most exciting parts about
business school is being able to
both learn from the folks around you, but
also that added benefit of your experience
enriching that of everyone else.
This year,
we're trying really intentionally as
the MBA admissions office to celebrate and
empower as many different voices as
possible in our different offerings.
Today we are talking about coming
to the GSB with a STEM background.
And so that is one of those things that
often we forget are part of our lived
experience.
And one of those perspectives
we bring to the table as well.
So, over the course of our conversation
today, I'll start with a brief intro.
We'll introduce the panelists.
I have a couple of Q&A
questions just to warm us up.
And then we'll be pulling
from the Q&A box.
So really looking forward to some of
the questions you all have today.
We have a poll up right now
just to help us get a sense for
where you are in the journey.
So go ahead and let us know.
I see a lot of folks are looking
to start an MBA program in 2022.
Some folks are looking beyond and
not sure what year you want to enroll.
And exploration, this a great
way to begin that exploration.
All right, cool.
So with that,
we can get over to the stars of our show.
Our panelists, if we can have, Graham,
if you can please introduce yourself and
maybe as part of that introduction,
what is one word your friends
would describe you as?
>> Thanks, Will.
Hi everyone,
really lovely to meet y'all and
to just a great opportunity,
I think to chat.
I'm really excited to be here.
So I graduated in 2019 from the MBA and
then 2020 with E-IPER program.
Originally from South Africa,
I did an undergrad in material science and
materials and metallurgical engineering.
And then spent about four and a half
years working in mining as an engineer
on operations, sort of dealing with broken
pumps and dealing with people and then,
night shift, that sort of thing.
Really engineering work both
in South Africa and Brazil.
And then after GSB, I'm moved
over to consulting with Deloitte.
I'm happy to sort of go
into that in more detail or
any area in more detail if you guys like.
And then I think very quickly
the one word my friends
would describe me as
is probably outdoorsy.
>> Your Zoom background speaks to
that description really easily.
>> In Jackson, Wyoming skiing
>> All right ,Carl.
>> Hi everyone, my name is Carl.
As you can see on the slide,
I did an MD prior to coming to the GSB
at McGill in Montreal, in Canada.
Prior to coming, I was doing my
residency in anesthesiology,
which I decided to go back to post GSB.
But throughout I've also had
business experiences and
consulting, did my
internship at Bain company.
And also currently am the president
of my professional associations.
So got to negotiate and advocate for
over 5,000 residents in my province and
negotiate their contracts.
So happy to talk more about that.
And if my friends had to describe me,
maybe it's just my job but
I would say calming and comforting.
>> All right, so
I'm going to go ahead and stop share so
we can focus on our panelists today.
So I'll start with you, Graham.
So coming from a background in mining,
why business school?
>> It's good question.
I think after sort of working for
four years on operations as
an engineer,
I said there are a couple pushing factors.
One was I wanted to understand
the business as a whole.
I knew how operations worked.
I knew how that side worked.
I knew the planning of that and etc.
I had no idea what happened on
the finance side of things.
I had no idea what happened
on my supply chain event.
I had no idea what happened in
human capital, human resources,
how strategy decisions were made.
All of these sort of things.
And I wanted to get a better understanding
of that with a view that one day
if I were to stay within mining and
sort of continue up the career path,
my background might be in
an engineering side, but
I would at least know and understand
what the rest of business was doing.
And then secondly, the second main
reason was, the career path and
mining as an engineer is pretty
well defined and it's pretty slow.
It's sort of two years in
exhibition two in expedition and
everything about 15 years on operations in
the middle of nowhere because most mines
don't happen to be on
San Francisco's doorstep.
They tend to be in the middle of nowhere.
And I wanted to get out of that, I didn't
want to have my career tied to being
an operations for
the next 15 years of my life.
And so I thought maybe it would
also help sort of expedite career
progression and give me more options.
>> Yes, so
how did you come to know that it was time?
Did you hear about an MBA from
other folks in your company?
Was this something you always
knew you wanted to do?
How did know it was time?
>> That's a great question, [LAUGH].
I don't know if there
is the right time to.
I was on a sort of rotational
leadership program with
a company I was working for,
which was five years.
And I was coming to the end of
that program said about a year,
three and a half to year four.
I sort of started having discussions
with some of my mentors,
many of them had done MBAs.
Many of the people who had been through
the program I was on before me had
done MBAs.
And it seemed a natural
progression from that program.
You sort of got to see
a lot of different things,
got to be working a bunch
of leadership positions.
And then there was no real progression for
you in the company,
there's no set if you're
going to go do this.
And that's how I went to engineering
route, which was long and slow and
I didn't really want to do.
An MBA seem to open up many more doors,
so.
>> The power that mentors can have
in your life is pretty incredible.
>> Absolutely, I mean,
one of those mentors ended up writing one
of my admission letters or
recommendation to [INAUDIBLE] and
has been a really great mentor and
for sure, even still.
>> Then Carl, how about you?
You started in healthcare, why an MBA?
>> Yeah, I think if you had asked me that
five, seven years ago when I started med
school, I would have thought it
was a really weird career move.
But pretty early,
when I started my residency I got really
frustrated about how
inefficient things were.
Honestly patients waiting for
a bed in the emerge for a days.
Surgeries getting cancelled,
improper resource allocation and
realize that the people making those
decisions were either business people
without a healthcare background.
So without really the tools to understand
the implications of their decisions.
Or healthcare people without
a business background.
So yeah,
they understand how doctors work but
they don't really understand operations or
human resources or supply chain.
All those things that are really
important when you're managing a large
organization like a hospital.
And so for me, it was really
a way to blend the two worlds and
to be able to bring back those
backgrounds into my industry to be
the one making the decision someday.
>> And then for you, so was it the
exposure in your workplace that got you to
feel like it was the right time?
Or how did you get exposed
to the MBA side of things?
>> It was kind of a fluke almost.
I think I thought about how can I
best get the that skill set and
thought about a bunch
of different programs.
I thought about maybe doing healthcare
administration, so be specific.
I thought about doing public policy,
public health and
thinking more about the interplay
with the government.
And I ended up settling in on to the MBA
because I thought it was the more
versatile degree and I would get to
meet people from different industries.
Healthcare can be very
in bred at times and so
we bring the same solution to
the same problems all the time.
So it's meeting people from these
different industries who knew nothing
about the hospital but knew lots of things
about mining or about consulting finance.
I thought it would be a super exciting
opportunity to be exposed to all those
different ways of thinking.
>> So for both of you coming from mining,
coming from healthcare, Carl,
you mentioned like almost coming
across this as a fluke Graham,
you had some mentors coming
into the B school experience.
As you were exploring your options,
as you were filling out your application,
even, were there any stereotypes or kind
of notions you had about business school?
And then did any of them come
true how did that hand out?
And so maybe Gram, let's start with you.
I think that mining background,
it's so fascinating
>> I think notions about business school
I think growing up certainly
an undergrad and on my career,
I think the notion what business school
is always probably people with a very
good set of consulting background,
people who are in strategy and finance and
running companies and
probably very much that.
And then business school itself being
hours upon hours upon hours of reading
cases and preparing cases for
class debates and stuff like that.
I think those are probably my
preconceived notions of business school.
And so people running around and
in black suits and ties and
having debates and discussing your
strategy companies would do and
where they shouldn't
mess with you like that.
None of that is true.
>> So what did you experience?
How would you describe kind of your
experience with some of those notions?
>> First I think the dress is very casual.
People go to class in flip flops and
shorts and a T shirt.
And then on other days,
maybe something more extravagant.
And I think that just the breadth of what
is current at business school is not
just discussing strategy and
finances and investment opportunities.
There's so much on soft skills.
There's so much on personal growth and
development.
There's so
much in different areas of the business.
Be it some of it is strategy and
finances but
there's also marketing and
sales and human resources.
There's just a lot, there's so
much that you can choose for and
there's very specific courses or
if you wanted to focus on family,
run businesses or a sort of focus on
healthcare specific classes on that.
So you can dive into an industry,
you can dive into a particular area.
There's just so many different options.
And I think one thing that also
pretty stands out from me from
Stanford is how open people are to
discussing different ideas.
And it might be ideas
about a new business.
It might be ideas about an investment, but
it could also be an idea about
somewhere you want to change the world.
Some new nonprofit you want to start,
some new tech startup you want to do.
It wasn't just about running around
in suits and ties discussing options.
>> Then Carl, for you I think I might have
watched a few too many hospital TV shows
where there is a very specific notion
of the business people in that world.
Did you have any preconceived notions or
my preconceived notions
about that world true?
>> [LAUGH] Yeah, I definitely did.
I think my opinion of business school and
business students at the time was there
people who are there because they
want to make a lot of money.
They don't necessarily care about the
impact they're going to have on the world.
It's going to be like all hard skills.
And there's going to be very little
dedicated to interpersonal skills.
And it was completely the opposite and
I found specifically.
So at Stanford,
especially here, people were so
focused on what their dream was, what
impact they wanted to have on the world.
What they wanted to change,
and also that there was so
many different classes that I took
that helped me become better at
relating to other people
like communicating.
And those I use every day even in my
clinical work, it's so useful to have
taken classes about how to break bad news
about how to have difficult conversations.
And so that was like the complete
opposite of what I expected really.
>> Yeah, nice.
So we're still in this world of
approaching business school,
you're maybe in the application cycle.
There are a couple questions popping up
in the Q&A box about telling your story.
Having come from a stem background myself,
I didn't know kind of what
that meant in a kind of leadership
professional space setting.
So how did you start to
talk about your story and
how did you approach that side of it?
And so maybe, Carl, since you were
talking a little bit about some of those
soft skills, and I think maybe even some
of your experiences at the GSB might have
been on in how do you share your story and
support others.
Can you tell us a little
bit more about that?
>> Yeah, I was just very honest.
I pretty much said what I'm telling you
right now that I think business is evil,
but I'm realizing more and
more that it's a necessary evil and
that I need to learn those skills
because I want to help my patients.
So talked a lot about what I do
the problems that I see day today,
what I want to fix and how I think
the GSB is going to help me get there.
So it was a lot of reflecting on
why is it that I want this degree?
What are the things that I
think I could do with it?
Who do I think I could help and
how can the GSB get me there,
and why is that the school
that I think can get me there?
>> Yeah, and for Gram, that reflective
element of the application process and
telling your story, is that something
that resonates for you as well or
how did that take shape?
>> Yeah, I think absolutely I
completely agree with Carl.
When you think about your story,
which is not something as an engineer,
we've never really done.
You're kind of an engineer,
this is what you're going to do.
There's no story.
I think that reflection
pieces could have go and
figuring out What are you doing,
what is important to you?
And very much a part of the application
process, what is most important to you?
And then as you think about that,
I wouldn't go so
far as to say I thought business was evil,
but it is certainly necessary.
It was something I thought was
perhaps boring and simple compared to
engineering problems but unnecessary
something that I knew nothing about.
And, I suppose from a business
perspective always thought the heart of
the business is in the side
that's doing this stuff.
If it's manufacturing, if it's mining,
if it's coding, it's the people building,
it's the people creating stuff.
It's the operation side and
then there's the business side.
It just facilitates that and supports it.
Now, I suppose I think it does more but
I think it's important to understand
both sides and really think about just
going back to thinking about story.
It's just understanding what you
want to get out of business school and
who are you, what's important to you?.
I think this part was important to know.
>> Yeah, I love those questions.
Who are you?.
What's important to you?.
What are you hoping to
get out of this process?.
>> And kind of, just to add to that,
I think is also figuring out your story I
think can be a bit of
an iterative process as well.
So, you said, yeah,
I think this is what's important to me.
And then for me that had been
renewable energy part of that.
And in my first year, I went to did an
internship in renewable energy company and
figured out what that is like and tried
an earlier stage startup and tested that.
And then you sort of come back and
say, okay, how does this fit my story?
Don't update it now,
I'm going to try something else.
That's it.
And that's, I think, a big part
of the purpose almost of an MBA.
And the benefit is you get
to figure out your story.
>> Yeah, there's a question here,
Graham from Priscilla,
who has a career in construction which is,
some similar to mining and a lot of ways.
And how do you talk about,
quote unquote fit for
an MBA coming from to use her words,
a harsh industry.
How did you approach
kind of that side of it?
>> I think that might depend on different
business schools and the culture.
I think it really depends on
the culture of the school.
I think Stanford is a very open culture.
The same time it's a very non harsh or
hard skills,
culture in the sense that I
think the first time I taught
someone else from mining,
they asked me if I made Bitcoin.
No, actual be in the gram,
and when you think about fit,
it runs stories fits in in some way or
other way,
it runs background as well in some way or
other way.
It might not be in every case in
every class in every discussion.
And I think you figure out,
it's part of figuring out your
story is where do I fit in?
Where can I contribute?
And so for me that was not
in the accounting classroom.
But there might have been other
classrooms on operations or
optimization was like,
okay, this is great event.
Or there are cases on perhaps
in a mining company so
when I get it I can give context here.
But then even outside of that, your
background is only one part of your story.
There's also where you want to go
is another part of your story, and
how can you contribute there?
How can you so for me,
I wanted to go to renewable energy.
So I did the IPA, I joined all the energy
classes, I joined the energy club.
And then I was probably learn more for
things in energy then for
my background and mining.
And so it's just a matter of figuring
out what's important to you and
then communicating that.
And even though mining
wasn't that important to me,
every time anything about money came up.
Everyone got pointed in my ear
towards me and said, go talk to him.
I had professors who say, professors
fashioned versus saying are they
interested in the mining space and
renewable energy.
And they would set up coffee chats for
me to come talk to me
then that introduced me to other people
in the broader both Stanford network and
even Palo Alto network of people
who are also working in mining.
And said, his rare mining MBA person,
talk to them.
So if you figure out what's important
to you, and you communicate that,
I think you find your fit and you'll find
the people with similar interests and
you'll find the people you
should be speaking to.
I hope that answers the question.
>> Yeah, that answered it beautifully, and
it pops up a follow up question I have for
Carl.
So Graham talked a little bit about some
of the contributions his perspective
contributed either in classroom community
and now kind of up broader scale of folks
who might've been interested in
are looking for someone to talk to and
learn more about.
What are some of the ways that you've
saw you've seen your pre MBA background
contribute or add value to either
the classroom or conversations you've had?
>> Well, I think there's
the obvious thing about like,
whenever healthcare pops up in a class
like people would all turn to me and
be like, Carl, what do you think
like is that is that how this goes?
Like we literally had a case in
our optimization class about or
scheduling at a hospital I had worked out.
And we had another one about how
to optimize the processes in
an anesthesia clinic.
So it was very easy for me to be like, so
these are how these things would happen.
But even beyond that,
I think a lot of the soft skills portions
like those are things that
I have gotten to practice.
And will get to practice more every day
like telling people that their
loved one is dying or has died.
Like those are very
difficult conversations and
there's a lot of parallels that you can
make between that and firing people.
Or telling them that the company
is going bankrupt or
making those big announcements
when you're a business leader.
And I think that I brought that
unique lens to those conversations
that added a lot to
the conversations really.
>> Nice, so, as we're talking about the
GSB and the business school experience,
let's start from the beginning of that,
from when classes started.
And this is a question
from the team out there.
Did you feel behind in classes coming
from a non-business background?
What was that transition into
the business classroom like for you guys?
So maybe Carl, we'll start with you and
then Graham, we'll hop over to you next.
>> Yeah, its something I'm worried
about a little before starting
knowing that I had the math in 10 year.
Knew virtually nothing
about accounting finance,
but for other classes you can think
of when you are thinking about your
first year business students is taking but
I will say that.
They're aware that people come
in with different levels and
so a lot of the intro classes are tearing.
To make sure that you enter in at
the right level and you make sure that you
learn what you need to learn but
also that everybody is stimulated.
The other thing I think is that
Coming from an MD background I had
already done graduate studies and
already had a sense of learning for
myself.
And I for what I need to learn and
for what I need for
my career versus learning in
order to get specific grades.
And so I think I came into the program
putting very little pressure on myself and
being, like,
I'm going to take as much as I can.
But if there's this one piece of
information I can't memorize it for
whatever reason.
And I think there's something I
can do with my time that would
add more value to this experience,
then that's what I'm going to do.
And I think that really helped me get
through with a minimal amounts of stress
compared to some other people who
didn't have that net view coming in.
>> Yes, and then Graham, how about you?
How was that transition coming from
a non business background into
the business classroom?
>> I think the key thing is Karachi
product is knowing what you want
to get out of it, and where you need
to put your time and attention to it.
And so if you're coming from
a non-digital background,
you say you already wanted to and
finances, okay?
Then you know you need to put your
attention into accounting and
econ and finance one on one and
ensure those classes.
Well, they take up more of your time, but
because you know where you want to put
your attention, I think that really helps.
And as Colin mentioned, the highlight
to the classes is the intro classes or
the first sort of quarter is really key.
Because then my first year accounting
class was everyone else who had
never done accounting before either.
Or the people who were accountants
were in the third advanced or
the level three class basically.
And they were discussing
some super advanced stuff,
I don't even know what
they were discussing.
But they weren't in our class, they're
being bored or asking questions that
are just so far above my head that
I have no idea what's going on.
So I think that's really critical.
I think the other element
to the transition
is just being back in a classroom and
having to study.
And just paying back in the classroom
if I hadn't done that for
five years, and that is a bit
of a shock to the system again.
Yeah, I think that's
something to be aware of.
But again,
I think the first quarter allows for
that transition instead of read the whole
first quarter sort of ramps up as well.
Under without doing any sports or
the activities where they're on hold and
go participate in those I
think really helps as well.
>> Then Graham there's a couple
questions in the Q&A box about like EI4,
did you know you wanted to do
the the program coming in?
And what was it like with
the two programs, like,
what was that experience like?
>> So I did know I want to
do the program coming in.
I happen to have a small group dinner
I think my first week at Stanford,
which was hosted by
a secondary year person.
And two of one and
there was also two classmates of mine
who are already in the active program.
And they sort of joined before or
as I joined the MBA, and
we just got talking about that,
and it sounded awesome.
And I think the next day I
filled out the application.
So that is more by chance, but
I definitely think it's worthwhile
looking into before if you know about it.
And then in terms of
managing the two programs,
it's very flexible in terms
of how you manage it.
I think there's a slightly higher
overall points requirement,
I can't remember exactly it's imagine 20,
240 or 100, 120 or something like that.
But you can do it anywhere from
an extra one quarter to an extra three
quarters at Stanford.
So you can really decide if
you want to almost, like,
sort of do 20 units every quarter for
the two years aone quarter.
You can finish it quickly in
just one additional quarter and
you will be busy but you can do it.
If you want to take a much
more leisurely pace for
the whole thing you can do three years
to do both the MBA and the undergrad.
And then have maybe one year being
busy and one year medium and
one really, really relaxed year.
You can have three pretty relaxed years,
you can really split
it up how you want to.
And managing that is up to you really and
once again,
what's important and
what you want to get out of it.
The most challenging
part is probably managing
the non-GSB classes that all courses.
Because some of those will occur one
year and they won't occur again or
they'll occur two years.
And then you budgeting on doing it in
the next year and it disappears or
they're only often in spring quarter.
So you got to try to budget that you're
going to do in spring quarter and
then manage conflicts with other
GSB classes you want to do.
So it's really about managing
the schedule of what's available when and
the conflicts that might occur from that.
>> Yeah, it's a little bit more logistics,
a little bit of pre-planning and
come through.
>> But there's great support for both GSB
and IPAR to help you manage that process.
And they are very accommodating and
flexible if you just talk to them and
start discussions early.
>> So continuing on the theme of things
you did while you're at the GSB,
Carl, you went from health care
went back into health care.
Graham you went from mining and
then you went into consulting, so
we have two different journeys here.
So Clara, if I can start with you,
there's a question here
in the inbox from Luis about,
wait, that's the wrong one.
Sorry, there is a question here about,
why did you choose Stanford for
healthcare?
>> There's a bunch of reasons,
I think one of it is just
the excellence of the hospital system.
And I knew that I could meet a lot of
people working within it, who I could see
as contacts, both within the business-side
and within the healthcare-side.
I did, for example,
do a quality improvement project with
Stanford Healthcare
while I was at the GSB.
The other reason which is kind of around
about way to go about health care but
this strong emphasis that Stanford
puts on interpersonal skills and
on communication skills.
And those are so
key in healthcare and I was, like,
even if I go into this degree and
decide that I hate business,
I never want to do it,
I never want to manage people.
I'm going to need to manage
relationships with patients and
difficult conversations.
And those are things that Stanford
is going to teach me no matter what.
And so I think that was the other
thing that really attracted me to
Stanford as someone
coming from healthcare.
I did take a lot of classes at the Med
school as well during my two years,
which I thought was a big plus.
The ability to take classes kind
of everywhere on campus was
very exciting to me.
And took a bunch of the the healthcare
electives that were offered at Stanford.
And really enjoyed them and learned a lot
about how the healthcare industry is
structured in the US and abroad.
And how to Manage large healthcare
organizations, what are the different
experiments that have been done
on the business side about that?
Those were all super cool experiences for
me.
>> So, question, so I'm going to
follow up a little bit here and
adapt the question from Daniel.
So that original question was from Nina,
so, sorry, I got names mixed up Nina.
But Daniel's asking a little bit
about transformation about moments or
an experience you have that
helped you change in a way.
How do you think you've changed
even if your career trajectory and
your career goal remained the same?
What are some of the ways you've
seen yourself kind of grow or
expand from your time at business school?
>> I think Stanford gives
you a lot of opportunity for
feedback from other people.
It's one of the things that we're known
for that we even make jokes about.
We give each other feedback
all the time and it's a gift.
And so I think very early on,
I was told something that had never
been told in health care, and
that's that I'm not very
emotionally expressive, [LAUGH].
But that sometimes means that
people take a bit of time to
figure out whether or not I like them.
And I got a million other little pieces
of feedback about how I interact
with other people on.
And thinking about those,
and trying to work on those,
and trying to find strategies
that work for me to,
I don't want to say overcome because
that's not really a default.
But to work around those
little quirks that I have,
have been really, really helpful in
how I interact with other people.
I was stuck in an apartment
with my sister for
three months at the beginning
of quarantine, for example.
And I was using some of the tricks
that I learned in interpersonal
dynamics every single day to prevent
us from murdering each other.
[LAUGH] because sometimes
it got a little heating.
>> Yes, and then Graham, you pivoted,
did you know that you wanted
to go into consulting?
Or how did you kind of,
how did you know that you were
going to go in that direction?
>> So I didn't know,
I will say that in my application,
I said I wanted go into consulting
to learn business skills.
And this sort of gets back
to iterating on your story.
So coming in, I thought this
sounds like a good story to tell.
And it made sense to me and it made sense
for how I saw my career progressing.
Then I joined Stanford decided I
want to go more into renewables and
energy and joined the.
And as I can't forget
this consulting thing,
let me go into clean energy startup,
can you try that?
Did that, just covered that startups,
depending very much on the startup or
not necessarily always
a great place to work.
And then sort of looked at,
okay, I've tried that.
Where do I see myself growing now?
And I actually came back
to the idea of consulting.
Because of, again,
it's almost an extension of an MBA.
Just learning skills, prosecutor
progression, opening more doors.
But then also just because I do enjoys
sort of solving different problems.
And consulting promised
to be a lot of that.
>> Yeah, how did you explore the startup
space, was this during the GSB, or
was this immediately after?
>> This was during the GSB.
So it was a lot of discussions with
some classmates even who had worked
in startups, who had their own
startups we are starting something.
It was with other alumni or
other people within the sort
of energy startup ecosystem
that classmates or
the Stanford community
helped connect me to.
And then speaking to them and
then sort of eventually picking one and
going for it.
So definitely be part of
exploring at the GSB.
>> And then same question from Daniel for
you about transformation and change.
Is there a moment or
experience that has helped
you kind of grow in some way shape or
form?
>> Currently that is a singular moment
where I had moment that I think,
but I think I just grew a lot of GSB and
really from people's diverse perspectives.
And I think it helped me
become even more open and
aware of how I interact with people with
different backgrounds and experiences.
And I've thought that growing up in
South Africa and dealing with a sort of on
a continuous basis that I was
already pretty good at this.
And then at the GSB, I think it just,
I grew so
much particularly in that regard.
And that was again,
the class interpersonal
dynamics that Carl mentioned.
Also as touchy feeling, something
might hurt that class was incredible.
But just the general discussions,
I think it would really help to break
down any stereotypes you might have.
Because you meet people
who just did not fit,
whatever stereotype you had about
someone with some bad code or
anything could be somebody completely
shattered that stereotype.
And it just made me question
a lot of stereotypes I had.
And then just that event,
you say you know what, this is just not
helping me having these stereotypes,
let me just try to forget those.
And I think that for me has been key.
>> I have a question here from a Matthias,
so we've kind of run the gauntlet
from kind of where you came from,
healthcare and mining,
approaching the process, that transition
between classes career exploration or
acceleration as the case may be.
This question is from Matthias,
how do you compare yourself
post to pre MBA at Stanford,
if you had to put it in a few words,
so go ahead and take a few moments.
Graham you just responded, so
maybe Carl, we'll start with you.
How would you describe yourself?
How would you compare yourself
pre versus post Stanford MBA?
>> I think it was a few things,
the one thing is it's really expanded
my idea of what's possible and
what are the different things I could do
and the different directions I could go.
I think one quick example is the power
of just asking for what you want.
That's something that the GSB taught me.
So in the fall quarter of my second year,
I emailed four different hospital CEOs
in Toronto, where I live currently,
and just told them my story, told them,
look, basically I want your job someday.
Would you mind getting on the phone for
20, 30 minutes and
telling me how you got there and
what do I do to do this?
And I don't think that's something
I would have had the courage or
even thought about doing before the GSB.
And they all responded, they all said yes,
they all got on the phone with me.
So I learned a ton from those
conversations and just knowing that
that's something I can do, I think was
a really big learning experience for me.
Deliberate board member and can ask much
better questions just because I have
a better sense of how
organizations are run.
I learned Spanish while
I was there as well.
So I've had a few patients who have
greatly benefited from that because they
had a couple who were just
lingual Spanish speakers and
got to give them their treatment in their
first language, which was pretty cool.
>> And Graham, what about you?
How would you describe
yourself pre versus post MBA?
>> So I think I was bowling
off what I said before.
I think I'm much more open to different
perspectives, different ideas,
aware of my own biases and
how I come across.
And then better able to work with
other people and like I said,
I communicate with them.
I think much more aware of how,
I think emotions play a role
in relationships as well.
I had always sort of seen showing
vulnerability and asking for
help as a weakness.
And I think Stanford really helped me
to see how those can be beneficial and
how they can be really actually
critical to building relationships.
Similarly then also just a lot of
the hard skills and I feel I might not
be an expert in accounting already
balance sheets or human resources,
but I could have a meaningful discussion
in any of those areas if I needed to.
And I sort of know what to ask,
what the critical things are and
how to dive deep into that.
And then also importantly know that
it's okay to ask for help and it's okay.
I can have an entry level discussion to
this, but I can't go deep who to speak to.
You can help me with this and
being comfortable to ask for that help.
>> Is there anything that
you would do differently?
So Graham, maybe we ca start with you.
>> Yeah, I would be more intentional
about how I spend my time.
I think there is the searching or
it is a bit of a culture but
it's not a necessarily real.
So it's a perception
of grace don't matter.
Academics don't matter.
We're here to have fun and
like socialize and network.
And while that's sure,
I think I took it almost too literally.
And I think there's more
that I could have learned,
which I would have liked to have learned
if I was more intentional about it.
At the same time, I think I would
have changed my strategy of forming
more meaningful connections with
maybe fewer people as opposed
to focusing on stronger
connections with fewer people.
And so I would have probably
changed those two approaches a bit.
But I was not too significant yet.
I think that just being really intentional
about how you spend your time is the most
important thing and now I would
be more intentional about that.
>> Cole what about yourself?
>> It's almost a joke, but I think I
would do it completely differently,
do everything differently.
Just so I could get an experience
that's just nothing like what I had.
I love the time I had that there's just so
many opportunities that come with
being at Stanford in the MBA program.
And there's always the sense that like,
whenever you're doing something
you're missing out on 10 others.
And so like just going back and open that
door that I didn't open, like maybe,
I don't know, learn how to code.
I go on that trip that I
didn't go to get to meet
the other people that
I didn't get to meet.
Lean and really hard on the like
hard finance skills and
see where that gets me and
if that gets me somewhere different
>> Were there any like classes or programs
specifically that you would go back and
try again if you had a second chance?
>> Yeah,
I think I would try to learn how to code.
I forget exactly what
class code those are.
But they're across the street
classes about how to use like R and
Python and I think it would be
very interesting skill to have.
Plus, there's a lot of things that you can
do with it in any industry you go into, so
maybe that's one thing that would try.
>> Yeah, I think you might be
referring to CS106 or CS105.
>> Yes.
>> Is it to [LAUGH] the known
classes on campus for
being in the computer science space.
>> Yes, exactly those.
>> Graham, I'm curious if there
was a class or program or
something that you would try if you had
a second chance at Business School.
>> Yeah, I really like cause approach of
saying try something completely new and
different and
deliver the same experience twice.
I think that's great.
[LAUGH] And I suppose to that I
would have probably leaned in more
on some of the heavy finances.
So, there's an investment class, there's
a financial modeling class by the Mars or
I think what he was trying to do and
really heavily there and
then maybe even like I did startup garage,
my very last quarter.
I didn't go to like to maybe
do it a bit earlier and
then also maybe try the school class.
I think it'd be really cool.
>> Can you tell us what startup garages?
>> Yes, startup garage is a class.
There are a couple of different
quarters to sort of build
on from each quarter where you
sort of come with an idea and
really try to build
a startup up from that idea.
And you've got a couple mentors
guides who act as professors.
Most of them are from industry, and
they sort of help guiding through
that process of helping to
hone in on what is your idea?
What is the MVP,
the minimum viable product.
Can you build that?
Can you test that?
Can you see there's a market for it?
And it'll just take you
through that process.
And it's been some really, they've
been some great startups that actually
come out there is successful startups
that have come out of that class.
>> Yeah.
>> And as we think back now on to
like the advice and best practice and
text part where [LAUGH] we get to impart
some of your wisdom from having lived it.
For folks, maybe we'll tailor
this specifically for folks,
maybe either coming from your own
professional or educational background or
from stem in general.
Do you have any tips, best practices,
words of wisdom that you could share with
folks as we close out today's events?
So Graham, maybe we can start with you.
So something I've said before I
keep on harping back to that is
just knowing what you want
to get out of the program.
And I think it is
particularly important for
STEM people that understand background.
And knowing because because that isn't
necessarily to say you want to get out,
finance knowledge or business acumen,
maybe you have an idea you want
to take three startup garage.
But I think it's knowing what you want to
get out and then really honing in on that.
The second comes to
a point someone raised and
asked about fitting in is
don't worry about that.
Figure out your story for yourself.
Be vocal about that.
And you will fit in by being yourself and
you will find the right place.
And there was a third thing I was
going to say which I've now forgotten.
But those two are, I think the third is,
is related to that.
If you want to focus on academics or
something for whatever you want to focus
on whatever is important to you,do that
regardless of what other people say.
And if you say you really want to
learn accounting and people saying,
why accounting it's so boring.
If that's what you want to do, that's
what's important to you, ignore them and
go and do it.
And remember that everyone is struggling
to figure out what they want to do
as well.
You're not alone in that.
>> What's the saying for
successful speech writing?
Tell them what you're going to say.
Then tell them and
then tell them what you just said.
So, already still practicing some of
those effective communication techniques.
And then Carl, what about yourself,
any tips, best practices,
words of wisdom you have for
folks out there?
>> Yeah Graham kind of stole mine
actually I was going to say, like,
come in with a list of the things
you want to accomplish and
try to make sure that your
time is aligned with those.
So, I came in with three specific
goals I wanted to learn how to
manage a healthcare organization,
learn better communication,
interpersonal skills and
learning new language.
And when looking at my classes when
looking at how I spent my time the clubs I
joined.
I was very intentional about doing that.
That being said, I think there's also
something to be said about exploring and
trying things that take you
out of your comfort zone.
So, yes, do come in with goals and
make sure you align your time with them.
But leave a little bit of space for
a little bit of whimsy and
last minute decisions and exploration.
>> Awesome.
We have one more poll if you guys if
everyone would be willing to help
us out here.
Thank you so much to our panelists,
Carl, Graham for
sharing your time, your story and
your wisdom with us all.
I encourage you to go ahead and
if you're interested in learning more,
including what other events we're having,
you can create your own personalized
dashboard at MyStanford.mba.
Where we'll help curate some of the things
that might be of most interest to you with
an answer of a few short questions.
So once again, thank you so
much for joining us today and
I hope to see you again at
some other events this summer.
Have a wonderful evening, day, morning,
wherever in the world you are.
Take care and stay safe.
[MUSIC]